there's a very clear definition of what
it means to be a man a successful man a
high value man a man of high status it
is very freaking clear and it takes many
years to become that dude most guys
aren't that's my point right is that
most guys are not it takes time it takes
work it takes effort no guy can just
wake up and be like I'm the man dog I'm
a high value man what's about to you I
don't know what it is because by your
definition anyone should be so basically
what y'all just reveal exposes that men
have standards for you guys no you guys
have zero standards you guys just want
us to cook and lay down and get
[Music]
we have a way higher standard for you
guys yes we do